[Música]
noticias de la salud con Marina sardina
y a más de un mes después de que se
detectara el primer positivo volvemos a
hablar del brote de ébola en uganda
Marina con el saludo para usted qué es
lo que está pasando en el país africano
Buenos días Ángela volvemos a hablar de
el ébola porque la el Ministerio de
Educación informó de que dos semanas
antes de el cierre por las vacaciones de
las escuelas van a cerrar las escuelas
debido a este brote de ébola y después
de que se confirmaran 23 casos de ébola
entre los alumnos a partir del 25 de
noviembre las escuelas preescolares
primarias y secundarias terminarán sus
clases y es que las aulas son un
altamente pobladas son un poco de
contagio para este reciente brote que
está sufriendo el país recordemos que
los casos confirmados desde el pasado 20
de septiembre cuando se declaró el brote
de ébola a desde entonces hay 135
positivos 53 muertes y también entre los
menores 23 casos en niños y niñas 8
decesos de y 16 Menores en aislamiento
según las cifras del gobierno desde el
pasado Domingo Este brote tiene una tasa
de letalidad del 33% y es por esto que
el Ministerio de Educación tomó esta
decisión de cerrar las aulas ante un
brote que está entre los 10 mayores que
ha registrado en todo el mundo el pasado
sábado también el gobierno extendió un
bloqueo de tres semanas en los distritos
vecinos de movende y casanda donde se
contabilizan el mayor número de casos
Pese a que el brote ya se ha extendido
por todo el país llegando incluso a la
capital kampala el presidente dijo que
no se necesitan restricciones a nivel
nacional pero los países vecinos también
están tomando precauciones en el control
de las llegadas de personas desde uganda
recordemos Ángela que el ébola es una
enfermedad que se propaga a través de
fluidos corporales cuyos síntomas
comunes son fiebre vómito y sangrado o
diarrea y tiene unas salsas de alta
mortalidad mortalidad Ángela
entendiendo la gravedad de este brote y
el que ya hubo hace algunos años en
África que fue muy causó muchísimas
muertes que se está haciendo para
contener esta crisis particular y existe
ya una vacuna Bueno pues Ángela sigo
jugando precisamente se ha enfrentado a
diferentes brotes de ébola predominando
dos tefas del virus las aire y la Sudán
que es la que está predominando ahora y
que en el año 2000 se cobró la vida de
más de 200 personas existen dos vacunas
autorizadas para la cepo para la cepa de
ébola zaire evolavirus la más común la
dosis el Venom y la dosis zambeno mapea
estas fueron las que ayudaron a paliar
la gran epidemia en África occidental
entre los años 2013 y 2016 pero no hay
una vacuna aprobada que actúe contra la
cepa Sudán No todo es negativo sin
embargo Ángela hay tres vacunas
candidatas experimentales la producida
por merck la compañía dijo que donará
50.000 dosis de las existencias para
finales de año otra del instituto de
vacunas sabín sin fines de lucro que
está vacuna está todavía en ensayo
clínico fase 1 y la universidad de
Oxford que también está en los primeros
ensayos de una vacuna que sugiera que
puede proporcionar inmunidad contra las
especies de virus de Sudán y las aire
los desarrolladores de la vacuna
anticipan que entre 20.000 y 30.000
dosis podrían estar disponibles a
finales de noviembre también una vez más
se necesitan fondos para la
investigación y el desarrollo de vacunas
que actúan contra las distintas cepas Y
es que las vacunas también como vimos
durante la pandemia de Kobe no pueden
cambiar las reglas del juego por eso los
investigadores se preguntan ahora si las
inyecciones con tecnología de ARN
mensajero que fueron las que se
utilizaron para el covid 19 podrían
transformar la lucha contra el ébola
actualmente vacunas contra el zaire
evolavirus utilizan tecnología en otro
con otro virus activo limitando así
quién puede recibirla por eso los
científicos creen que las inyecciones de
aire en el mensajero podrían remedar
remediar Perdón algunos desafíos puesto
que estos no contiene el virus sino que
codifica la proteína clave que se
encuentra en la superficie del virus
recordemos que cuando el ARN mensajero
ingresa en las células de una persona
estas comienzan a producir la proteína
desencade desencadenando una respuesta
inmunitaria al virus Ángela muy bien
Marina vamos a hacer un cambio de tema
porque hay mucho más que hablar hay un
nuevo estudio del diario internacional
de ginecología y obstetricia y señala
que los fuegos de leña en interiores que
son tan comunes en la región
latinoamericana son peligrosos Para
algunas mujeres embarazadas
qué es lo que es lo que dice el informe
si Ángela pues estos fuegos de leña
estas cocinas de leña tan comunes que
utilizaban nuestras abuelas también
vemos ahora que es frecuente en muchas
comunidades que se sirven utilizando y
esta nueva investigación encontró un
vínculo entre las muertes relacionadas
con el humo tóxico de la cocina y la
eclampsia un estudio se llevó a cabo en
ocho países de ingresos bajos y medios
que es precisamente donde ocurren el 94%
de las muertes maternas Y es que la
eclampsia bueno es una enfermedad rara
una rara condición que se da durante el
embarazo en la que la presión arterial
alta provoca convulsiones potencialmente
mortales las mujeres compré eclampsia
tienen un riesgo significativamente
mayor a sufrir esto si cocinan a fuego
abierto con estos fogones de leña esta
condición es una de las principales
causas de mortalidad materna en el mundo
con 150 decesos cada día los humos
tóxicos
exacerban también el riesgo de hipoxia
placentaria cuando el suministro de
oxígeno del feto se ve afectado Esto es
lo que nos dice el reporte
nuestros datos sugieren que la
contaminación del hogar en el interior
puede explicar una reducción aguda del
umbral de convulsiones en la
preeclampsia posiblemente relacionada
con la hipoxia la contaminación del aire
doméstico por el uso de estufas para
cocinar en interiores en Nigeria se ha
relacionado con medidas histológicas de
hipoxia placentaria Crónica y las
células cerebrales son sensibles a la
falta de oxígeno lo que puede causar
convulsiones
Ángela y recordemos que una vez más
estos riesgos están potenciados por las
condiciones de vulnerabilidad y el
contexto empobrecido que habitan Estas
mujeres siendo las mujeres de la
ruralidad y las mujeres de países de Sur
global las que tienen mayores tasas de
mortalidad lo que explica también las
altas desigualdades en la salud materna
Pues gracias a ustedes por traer esta
discusión a la mesa Marina ya por hoy es
libre para hacer otras tareas
periodísticas y nos vemos mañana Gracias
muy bien y nos vamos en directo a Pa